D
THEM A MESSAGE RIGHT AT
THE POLLS.
THEY ALL NEED TO BE FIRED.
HERE NOW WITH REACTION,
NEW HAMPSHIRE GOVERNOR
CHRIS SUNUNU, AND NEW
HAMPSHIRE SENATE
CANDIDATE, REPUBLICAN
GENERAL DON BULDUC IS WITH
US.
THANK YOU FOR BOTH BEING
WITH US.
GENERAL, A GUY TOOK A
SWIPE AT YOU LAST NIGHT.
I KNOW YOU SERVED TEN
TOURS OF DUTY.
YOU HAVE TWO PURPLE
HEARTS, FIVE MEDALS OF
VALOR, A TRUE AMERICAN
HERO.
I AM SURE SOMEBODY TAKING
A SWING AT YOU IS NOT
UNUSUAL TO YOU, NOT
COMFORTABLE THOUGH ON THE
OTHER HAND.
>> WELL, THANK YOU, SEAN.
MY BEST TO YOUR VIEWERS.
GREAT TO BE ON.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT YOU HAVE TO GUARD
AGAINST ALL THE TIME.
I AM THANKFUL FOR THE
POLICE BEING THERE TO
RESPOND QUICKLY.
CERTAINLY HAD SOME
SUPPORTERS THAT RESPONDED
QUICKLY.
BUT THIS GUY IDENTIFIED
HIMSELF QUICKLY.
ALL KEPT A GOOD EYE AND I
WAS ABLE TO REACT IN
PLENTY OF TIME SO NOTHING
HAPPENED, THE POLICE
REACTED IN PLENTY OF TIME
AND THE GENTLEMAN WAS
ARRESTED AND REMOVED FROM
THE SCENE.
>> Sean: YOU DID A GREAT
JOB DURING THE DEBATE.
GOVERNOR SUE NEW SHEPARD
-- SUNUNU, YOU GO UP FOR
RE-ELECTION EVERY TWO
YEARS.
YOUR DAD IS PROBABLY VERY
PROUD OF YOU, AS HE SHOULD
BE.
THE REASON I ARGUE YOU'RE
SO SUCCESSFUL, YOU ARE A
SIMPLE, COMMON SENSE
CONSERVATIVE.
WHEN I LISTEN TO YOU
SPEAK, IT DOESN'T GET
COMPLICATED, YOU'RE THERE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND THEY
APPRECIATE IT.
>> LOOK, POLITICS ISN'T
HARD.
IT IS JUST THAT WE HAVE SO
MANY ENTRENCHED
POLITICIANS THAT TRY TO
CONVINCE SOMETHING OF
SOMEONE THEY'RE NOT.
THEY DON'T CONNECT WITH
FOLKS ON A VERY GENUINE
LEVEL.
HERE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ALL
ABOUT.
WE'RE ABOUT THAT GRASS
ROOTS, GRASS TOPS
CONNECTION, LOCAL CONTROL,
LIMITED GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S WHY GENERAL BOLDUC
IS DOING SO WELL.
HE HAS DONE LIKE 70, 80
TOWN HALLS, WILLING TO
TALK ABOUT ANY ISSUE TO
ANYONE.
DOESN'T MEAN WE'RE
CONVINCING FOLKS IT IS OUR
POLICY OR THE HIGHWAY,
JUST CONNECTING WITH
FOLKS, LISTEN WITH AN OPEN
EAR, UNDERSTAND THEIR
ISSUES.
GENERAL BOLDUC IS RUNNING
AGAINST MAGGIE HASSAN WHO
DOESN'T DO TOWN HALLS AND
DOESN'T CONNECT WITH
ANYBODY, SHE'S SPENDING 50
MILLION BUCKS TO CONVINCE
FOLKS SHE HAS BEEN HERE.
IT IS WHAT NEW HAMPSHIRE
IS ABOUT.
THAT'S WHY THE GENERAL IS
HAVING SO MUCH SUCCESS.
BE YOURSELF, BE NORMAL.
IT AIN'T TRICKY.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, I LOOK
AT YOUR POLICIES.
I WATCHED THE DEBATE.
AND GENERAL BOLDUC, I
THOUGHT YOU WON HANDS
DOWN, DID A TERRIFIC JOB,
AND I WAS WATCHING A VERY
POLISHED, VERY SEASONED
POLITICIAN THAT WOULDN'T
EVEN ANSWER A SIMPLE
QUESTION, DO YOU HAVE ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION.
THE ANSWER WAS OBVIOUSLY
NO.
AND I WAS THINKING ABOUT
YOUR POLICIES, GOVERNOR,
IN PARTICULAR AND WHAT IS
SO SUCCESSFUL, WHAT MADE
YOU SO POPULAR.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE THING
THAT I HEARD FROM SENATOR
HASSAN THAT MATCHES UP TO
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE, IN THE GRANITE
STATE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHY THE
PEOPLE WOULD ELECT YOU BY
18 POINTS, 20 POINTS AND
THEN ALSO ELECT HER.
THE SENATOR AGREES WITH
NOTHING YOU STAND FOR.
>> NO.
THAT'S WHY IT IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT
OF SUCCESS IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE ON TUESDAY.
THE DEMOCRATS, AGAIN,
THEIR ENTIRE CAMPAIGN,
LOOK AT WHAT THEY TRIED TO
PUSH NOT JUST WITH ME AND
THE GENERAL, IT IS
NEGATIVE.
THEY'RE NOT ABOUT
ANYTHING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO
BE.
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, MORE
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE, WE
HAVE TO LOOK YOU IN THE
EYE, BUY YOU OFF AS A
PERSON FIRST.
THAT'S WHY THE TOWN HALLS
THE GENERAL DOES ARE
IMPORTANT.
BEING OUT THERE 24/7 FOR
THE LAST YEAR.
DOESN'T MEAN YOU AGREE
WITH EVERY POINT BUT HE IS
CONNECTING AND HE IS
LISTENING TO THEM.
PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW AS
INDIVIDUALS THEY'LL BE
TREATED AS INDIVIDUALS,
NOT ABOUT BIG GOVERNMENT
AND A SYSTEM, IT ISN'T
ABOUT US, IT IS ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS AND CREATING
THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
THE GENERAL WILL BRING TO
WASHINGTON.
BEHOLDEN TO NOBODY, SHAKE
THINGS UP.
WE ALL WANT WASHINGTON TO
CHANGE.
EVEN DEMOCRATS WANT
WASHINGTON TO CHANGE
FUNDAMENTALLY, BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, CAN'T KEEP
SENDING THE SAME PEOPLE
BACK AND EXPECT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
THAT'S WHY YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE CHANGE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IT WILL BE A GOOD WEEK
THIS WEEK.
>> Sean: WE SAY BEING A
POLITICIAN YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE A PUBLIC SERVANT.
YOU SERVED THIS COUNTRY
OVER 30 YEARS, I MENTIONED
TWO PURPLE HEARTS, FIVE
MEDALS OF VALOR, YOU
SERVED YOUR COUNTRY.
I LISTEN TO SENATOR HASSAN
REFER TO ALL THE POSITIONS
YOU TOOK AND THINGS YOU
WERE ADVOCATING, YOU SAID
I NEVER VOTED ON ANY OF
THESE, I WASN'T THERE.
YOU WERE THE ONE THAT WAS
THERE VOTING WITH BIDEN
AND SCHUMER 98% OF THE
TIME.
SHE WAS PRETTY MUCH A
RUBBER STAMP.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
PRETTY EFFECTIVE TACTIC OF
YOURS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE
PEOPLE OF NEW HAMPSHIRE
TONIGHT HAVING THE GREAT
SUPPORT OF A VERY POPULAR
GOVERNOR I THINK IS VERY
POWERFUL FOR YOU.
I THOUGHT YOUR MESSAGE WAS
COMMON SENSE CONSERVATISM.
>> I AM THANKFUL TO HAVE
THE GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT AND
I'M THANKFUL TO HAVE HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
HE UNIFIED THE PARTY.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S
SCARING THE DEMOCRATS HERE
IS A UNIFIED REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
YOU KNOW, HE MANAGED TO
SUPPORT THE TICKET FROM
BOTTOM TO THE TOP, TOP TO
THE BOTTOM, AND THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE.
A UNIFIED REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR
DOING THAT BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS ME ON THE GROUND TO
BE MORE EFFECTIVE.
YOU KNOW, HIS ABILITY TO
RESONATE WITH THE
POLITICAL ELECTORATE FROM
REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT,
INDEPENDENT, LIBERTARIAN,
FREE STATER IS VERY
POWERFUL.
THAT ENABLES US AS WELL.
THE POINT HE MAKES ABOUT
BEING YOURSELF AND GETTING
OUT THERE ON THE GROUND
TWO YEARS, 78 T BE EXACT,
TWO TODAY TOWN HALLS, HERE
PARTICIPATING, IT WAS
AWESOME.
THIS IS THE WAY IT HAS TO
BE DONE.
>> Sean: I READ, GOVERNOR,
IN "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL" THAT THERE MIGHT
BE A BLACKOUT THIS WINTER
IN ALL OF NEW ENGLAND
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH NATURAL GAS
AVAILABLE TO POWER THE
GRID.
ALSO I READ THAT PEOPLE
CAN EXPECT HEATING BILLS
TO GO UP MINIMUM 30%, BE
IT GAS OR OIL.
IS THAT WHAT NEW HAMPSHIRE
IS FACING?
>> WITHOUT A DOUBT.
UNFORTUNATELY ALL OF NEW
ENGLAND IS TIED TO THIS
ENERGY GRID.
SOME OF THE BAD DECISIONS
BY NOT JUST OUR
NEIGHBORING STATES BUT
SPECIFICALLY OUT OF
WASHINGTON, NORMALLY WHEN
DEMAND GOES UP ON A COLD
COUPLE OF WEEKS IN JANUARY
PRODUCTION GOES UP.
OIL OR NATURAL GAS COMES
THROUGH NEW YORK, ALL GETS
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS NEW
ENGLAND.
UNFORTUNATELY NOW THERE'S
NO INCENTIVE TO INCREASE
PRODUCTION, THERE'S
DISINCENTIVE.
WE ARE NOT TAPPING OUR OWN
RESOURCES.
HEATING OIL IS A HUGE
DEAL.
PEOPLE ARE PAYING 13 BUCKS
A MONTH FOR HEATING OIL.
LACK OF KEROSENE.
LACK OF CDL DRIVERS
BECAUSE OF REGULATION ON
DRIVERS.
IT IS LACK OF MATERIALS,
INFLATIONARY COST AND IT
BAFFLES ME THEY GO BACK TO
STUFF FROM A COUPLE YEARS
AGO, WHAT HAPPENED IN
2020.
VOTERS LOOK FORWARD.
VOTERS VOTE IN THEIR
FAMILY'S INTEREST AS THEY
SHOULD.
THAT'S WHY INFLATION AND
COST OF FUEL AND COST OF
HEATING AND FRANKLY THE
REALISTIC FEAR PEOPLE HAVE
ABOUT WHAT MAY COME IN A
COLD WINTER IN NEW
ENGLAND, THAT'S GOING TO
DRIVE THE VOTE THIS
TUESDAY.
>> Sean: I COULDN'T AGREE
MORE.
GENERAL BOLDUC, IT IS
GREAT THAT YOU HAVE THE
GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT.
GOVERNOR, WE APPRECIATE
YOU AND YOU BEING ON THE
PROGRAM.
GENERAL, WE'RE WATCHING
YOUR RACE.
I THINK A VERY WINNABLE
RACE.
IT WOULD BE A BENEFIT TO
THE GOVERNOR AND THE WHOLE
STATE OF NEW HAMPSHIRE TO,
WELL, SEND SENATOR HASSAN
BACK HOME TO NEW
HAMPSHIRE, MAYBE LEARN A
LESSON OR TWO, C